> JUST IN TO CNN, WE'VE NOW
LEARNED THAT MULTIPLE CURRENT
AND FORMER U.S. OFFICIALS HAVE
BEEN GIVEN EXTRA SECURITY DUE TO
IRANIAN THREATS.
THIS COMES AFTER THE U.S.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CHARGED A
FORMER IRANIAN REVOLUTIONARY
GUARD MEMBER WITH TRYING TO
ASSASSINATE FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER JOHN BOLTON.
A SOURCE REVEALING TO CNN THAT
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO WAS TARGETED BY IRANIANS
AS WELL.
CNN NATIONAL SCULPTURE
CORRESPONDENT KYLIE ATWOOD HAS
OUR REPORT.
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE MAN THE
FBI ALLEGES TRIED TO HIRE ANSIS
A AN ASIS A ANYONE, SHAHRAM
POURSAFI, ALLEGEDLY A MEMBER OF
IRAN'S REVOLUTIONARY GUARD
CORPS.
IN 2021 THEY SAY HE TRIED TO GET
AN INFORMANT TO HIRE SOMEONE TO
ELIMINATE SOMEONE.
THAT NUMBER EVENTUALLY GREW TO
$300,000.
POURSAFI EVEN SENT SCREEN SHOTS
OF BOLTON'S HOME ADDRESS AND
PHOTOGRAPHS OF STACKS OF HONE
MONEY.
HE SAID THE KILL SHOTGUN HAPPEN
IN BOLTON'S OFFICE GARAGE WITH
NOTING IT WAS A HIGH TRAFFIC
AREA.
THE FBI ALSO ALLEGES THAT
POURSAFI HAD A SECOND JOB FOR $1
MILLION.
THE TARGET OF THAT JOB?
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO.
ACCORDING TO A SOURCE FAMILIAR
WITH THE INVESTIGATION AND A
SOURCE CLOSE TO POMPEO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SAID
THIS ABOUT THE MOTIVATION BEHIND
THE BOLTON PLOT.
THINKING ASSASSINATION PLOT WAS
UNDERTAKEN IN APPARENT
RETALIATION FOR THE JANUARY 2020
KILLING OF QASSEM SOLEIMANI.
>> Reporter: POMPEO WAS
SECRETARY OF STATE AT THE TIME
OF THE ASSASSINATION.
WHICH SAW THAT HE WAS PLOTTING
FURTHER PLANS TO TAKE DOWN
AMERICANS, IN SOME CASES MANY
AMERICANS.
WE TOOK THE RIGHT ACTION TO
DEFEND AND PROTECT AMERICA.
>> Reporter: AND THOUGH BOLTON
WAS NO LONGER IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WHEN THE AIR
STRIKE WAS CARRIED OUT AGAINST
SOLEIMANI, A TOP IRANIAN GENERAL
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SAID
WAS PLANNING ON ATTACKS ON
AMERICANS, BOLTON HAS LONG
ADVOCATED FOR MORE HAWKISH U.S.
POLICY TOWARDS IRAN.
AFTER THE SOLEIMANI
ASSASSINATION, BOLTON TWEETED,
QUOTE, CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL
INVOLVED IN ELIMINATING QASSEM
SOLEIMANI.
HOPE THIS IS THE FIRST STEP TO
REGIME CHANGE IN TEHRAN.
AND AFTER TODAY'S NEWS, BOLTON
THANKED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
THE FBI, AND THE SECRET SERVICE
AND SAID THAT IRAN'S RULERS ARE
LIARS, TERRORISTS AND ENEMIES OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THE SUSPECT HAS NOT BEEN
ARRESTED BUT IS WANTED BY THE
FBI AFTER SEEKING TO CARRY OUT
THIS PLOT.
>> THIS WAS NOT AN IDLE THREAT,
AND THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
WE UNCOVERED BRAZEN ACTS BY IRAN
TO EXACT REVENGE AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS ON U.S. SOILS.
>> Reporter: THE PLOT AGAINST
BOLTON IS JUST THE LATEST
ALLEGATION OF IRAN PLANNING
ATTACKS ON U.S. SOIL.
IN 2011, U.S. AUTHORITIES SAID
IRAN WAS PLANNING TO BOMB A D.C.
RESTAURANT TO KILL THEN SAUDI
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED STATES
AND CURRENT SAUDI MINISTER OF
STATE FOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
>> THIS IS HAPPENING IN AMERICA.
>> Reporter: AND JUST LAST WEEK,
IRAN BEYOND JOURNALIST AND
ACTIVIST MASSI, A U.S. CITIZEN
WHO LIVES IN NEW YORK BLAMED THE
IRANIAN REGIME AFTER A MAN
CARRYING AN ASSAULT RIFLE WAS
ARRESTED IN HER NEIGHBORHOOD.
COMING A YEAR AFTER AUTHORITIES
SAY THE REGIME WAS PLANNING TO
KIDNAP HER.
ALINE AJAD DELIVERED THIS
MESSAGE ON CNN.
>> GO TO HELL.
I'M NOT SCARED OF YOU.
>> Reporter: NOW TODAY, WOLF, WE
ARE HEARING FROM THE CURRENT
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER JAKE
SULLIVAN, WHO SAID THAT ANY
ACTION AGAINST ANY U.S. CITIZEN
BY THE IRANIANS WILL BE MET WITH
SEVERE CONSEQUENCES.
WE'RE ALSO HEARING FROM THE
IRANIANS WITH THE IRANIAN
FOREIGN MINISTRY SPOKESPERSON
WARNING AGAINST ANY ACTION
AGAINST ANY IRANIAN CITIZENS
BASED ON WHAT THEY SAY ARE
BASELESS ACCUSATIONS.
WOLF?
>> KYLIE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KYLIE ATWOOD REPORTING.
LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF THIS AND
MORE WITH THE FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER JOHN BOLTON.
AMBASSADOR BOLTON, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
THE SUSPECT PUT A $300,000 PRICE
TAG ON YOUR HEAD.
WHAT GOES THROUGH YOUR MIND,
AMBASSADOR, HEARING THE DETAILS
OF THIS PLOT AS EXPLAINED TODAY
IN GREAT DETAIL BY THE U.S.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT?
>> WELL, I WAS EMBARRASSED AT
THE LOW PRICE.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
HIGHER.
BUT I GUESS MAYBE IT WAS THE
EXCHANGE RATE PROBLEM OR
SOMETHING.
I READ THE DOCUMENTS WITH GREAT
INTEREST.
I HAD NOT SEEN IT BEFORE.
I WAS NOT AWARE OF MANY OF THE
SPECIFICS IN IT, ALTHOUGH
OBVIOUSLY I HAD LONG HAD A
GENERAL UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE THREAT WAS.
AND I THINK IT'S QUITE CORRECT
TO SAY MANY OTHER AMERICANS ARE
IN THE TARGETS OF THIS REGIME.
IT TELLS YOU WHAT THE REGIME IS.
IT TELLS YOU ABOUT ITS
CHARACTER.
AND FRANKLY, FROM MY POINT OF
VIEW, THE REGIME'S TERRORIST
ACTIVITIES ARE JUST THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE COIN OF ITS NUCLEAR
WEAPONS PROGRAM.
AND ANY IDEA THIS REGIME WILL
ADHERE TO ITS COMMITMENTS ON
ANYTHING IS JUST A TERRIBLE
DELUSION.
>> WE NOW KNOW THE SECOND JOB
WAS FOR ONE MILLION, AND THAT
INVOLVES MIKE POMPEO, THE FORMER
CIA DIRECTOR.
DID YOU KNOW HE WAS ALSO BEING
TARGETED?
HAVE YOU SPOKEN WITH HIM,
AMBASSADOR?
>> I HAVE NOT SPOKEN WITH HIM.
I WAS NOT AWARE THAT HE WAS
TARGETED AS REFERRED TO IN THE
CHARGING DOCUMENT THAT WAS
UNSEALED TODAY.
I'VE SEEN THE PRESS REPORTS.
AND AGAIN, IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE
ME.
I THINK THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VULNERABLE TO THESE IRANIAN
EFFORTS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, I'M AFRAID WE
MAY LEARN MORE.
NOT JUST FORMER PUBLIC
OFFICIALS, BUT AS YOU JUST
INDICATED, THE PRIVATE AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHO DISAGREE WITH THE
REGIME.
>> CNN HAS IN FACT LEARNED THERE
ARE MULTIPLE CURRENT AND FORMER
U.S. OFFICIALS WHO ARE NOW
ALREADY GETTING PERSONAL
SECURITY DUE TO THESE IRANIAN
THREATS.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHO SOME
OF THOSE OFFICIALS ARE?
>> WELL, I DO HAVE A SENSE.
SOME HAVE TOLD ME.
I DON'T THINK I OUGHT TO BE THE
ONE DIVULGING IT ON TELEVISION.
BUT AS I SAY, I THINK THE NATURE
OF THE REGIME DRIVES IT TO THIS
KIND OF ACTION.
AND I THINK IT'S A BIG MISTAKE
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CONTINUE TO SHOW WEAKNESS TO
IRAN BY BEGGING TO GET BACK INTO
THE 2015 NUCLEAR DEAL.
I THINK IT ENCOURAGES TEHRAN TO
ENGAGE IN JUST THESE KINDS OF
TERRORIST TAITTS.
>> I KNOW YOU'VE SAID PUBLICLY
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP ACTUALLY LIFTED YOUR
SECRET SERVICE PROTECTION AFTER
YOU LEFT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, AND YOU HAD TO
RENEW YOUR REQUEST FOR
PROTECTION UNDER PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
WHICH WAS IN FACT GRANTED.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THIS
PROCESS?
>> WELL, THE DAY I RESIGNED, THE
SECRET SERVICE PROTECTION WAS
WITHDRAWN.
THE AGENTS WERE PULLING THE
BELLS AND WHISTLES OFF THE
OUTSIDE OF MY HOUSE.
NORMALLY, A DETAIL WOULD
CONTINUE FOR ANOTHER THREE
MONTHS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
JUST OUT OF A SENSE OF
PRECAUTION.
BUT THAT WAS NOT THE WAY THINGS
WERE DONE.
AS THE FBI WARNINGS TO ME GREW
MORE SEVERE AS TIME WENT ON, AND
THE FBI WAS DOING THIS PURSUANT
TO THEIR PROCESS CALLED DUTY TO
WARN WHEN THEY LEARN OF A
FOREIGN THREAT AGAINST AN
AMERICAN, EVENTUALLY BY THE LATE
FALL OF 2021, I ASKED IF IT'S
THIS SERIOUS, PERHAPS THE SECRET
SERVICE SHOULD BE INVOLVED.
AND ULTIMATELY, PRESIDENT BIDEN
MADE THAT DECISION, AND I
APPRECIATE IT OBVIOUSLY.
>> AS YOU SHOULD.
DOES SOMETHING LIKE THIS,
AMBASSADOR BOLTON, CREATE FEAR
IN YOU?
OR IS THIS PART OF WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE A PUBLIC OFFICIAL?
>> WELL, IT'S NOT SOMETHING I
VOLUNTEERED FOR, THAT'S FOR
SURE.
IT GOES WITH THE TERRITORY.
I FEEL I'M IN VERY GOOD HANDS
WITH THE SECRET SERVICE.
LOOK, I THINK EVERYBODY THAT
I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH WHO
HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS, THE
ATTORNEYS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, CERTAINLY THE
OUTSTANDING WORK DONE BY THE FBI
AND THE WORK EQUALLY OUTSTANDING
BY THE SECRET SERVICE, I'M NOT
WORRIED.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE TODAY'S
DEVELOPMENTS SHOULD PUT THE NAIL
IN THE COFFIN ON THE EFFORTS
THAT ARE ONGOING RIGHT NOW TO
TRY TO REVIVE THAT SO-CALLED
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK, I THINK THE DEAL WAS A
MISTAKE IN 2015.
IT HASN'T GOTTEN ANY BETTER WITH
AGE.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN ON
ITS KNEES IN VIENNA BEGGING TO
GET BACK INTO THE DEAL WHICH
SENDS SIGNALS OF WEAKNESS NOT
JUST TO TEHRAN, BUT AROUND THE
WORLD.
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT THE
REGIME IN TEHRAN IS WILLING TO
GIVE UP ITS PURSUIT OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
OUR ALLIES IN THE REGION, SAUDI
ARABIA, THE UNITED ARAB
EMIRATES, ISRAEL CLEARLY SEE
THIS DANGER, AND NOW IN THE
UNITED STATES IF THIS DOESN'T
SHOW ANYTHING ABOUT IRAN'S
WILLING TO TRY AND INTIMIDATE
ITS ADVERSARIES, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT ELSE TO SAY.
I THINK WE OUGHT TO PUT THE
KIBOSH ON THESE NEGOTIATIONS AND
DEAL WITH THE GROWING THREAT
THAT IRAN POSES AND NOT TRY TO
APPEASE THEM.
>> WHILE I HAVE YOU, AMBASSADOR,
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION TO
THE FBI SEARCH OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FLORIDA HOME
RELATED TO HIS HANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, SOME
HIGHLY CLASSIFIED.
AS HIS FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
DIRECTOR, DO YOU BELIEVE A CRIME
MAY ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED?
>> WELL, I THINK THIS IS A VERY
UNCERTAIN AREA.
AND I THINK ALTHOUGH THE PAST
COUPLE OF DAYS HAVE BEEN FILLED
WITH COMMENTARY BY ALL KINDS OF
EXPERTS, THE REALITY IS WE
REALLY KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
WE CERTAINLY AT THIS POINT KNOW
ALMOST NOTHING ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S THINKING
IN AUTHORIZING THIS SEARCH.
I KNOW AND AS AN ALUMNUS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FULLY
APPRECIATE THAT IT'S CONTRARY TO
NORMAL PRACTICE TO TALK ABOUT AN
ONGOING INVESTIGATION FOR VERY,
VERY GOOD REASONS.
NONETHELESS, GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WE'RE IN NOW, I
THINK ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND WOULD BE VERY WELL
ADVISED TO SAY SOMETHING ON THIS
SCORE.
I THINK HE'S GOT EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE BEFORE DISTORTIONS ABOUT
HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
NORMALLY WORKS GET INTO THE
BLOODSTREAM OF THE BODY POLITIC.
IT'S ALREADY WELL ON THE WAY